foreign
and we have gone live I am going to tell
you if other scan here I'm not sure
yeah hold on just let me uh send a
message to Rick vendra
okay
can you hear Rick vendra
yeah uh I'm not sure like let me
introduce myself and uh let's get
started uh
okay I don't know if you can see me and
also can you hear me right
if you can please can anyone know if you
confirm me in the chat window
good so thank you so much information
all right I need to start our live
stream for our LinkedIn audience it will
take me just a few seconds and then
we'll get going
apologize for this so you have audio
problems on
Rock vendor's side
where we can hear him but he can't hear
us
got that sorted but in the meantime oops
what is system design why it is
important and then in the next 45
minutes I'll be spending the time for
Designing the Instagram okay that's the
topic yeah it's it is definitely very
difficult for me to talk everything
about it but I'll try to keep it
minimalistic and I'll try to keep as
much as possible
brief okay I want to cover most of the
things but I'll see how much we can
cover and uh I'll try to keep it again
try to cover end to end as much as
possible
cool so about myself to myself
across platforms and I also conduct
trainings and regarding DSA algo system
design and then full stack man mean all
those topics I'll be just like
conducting sessions across multiple
clients including simply known
that's about me and uh today's agenda
mainly is uh will understand what is
system design and it's very important
for us to understand how an application
work and we'll also see if we were in
design in any website or anything what
concepts and components we need to keep
in mind and in the time we will be
designing a design problem called
Instagram okay
so this is what the protest agenda will
be
okay now what is system design can
people get confused in this it's a
process of defining components apis data
type is tables
etc for the system to satisfy specific
specified functional non-functional
requirements people who are in the
college grants time for you guys it
might sound a very Greek word for you
what is this requirements and all maybe
you guys might have learned in your
college days to build an application or
a software a requirement phase is very
important right this is what actual
application system design functional
non-functional requirements what has
been practiced in real time in the
industries
so now let's break it down to make it
easier for our people to understand what
is it the system design let me make it
full screen
okay okay system design means it's a
combination of the system the design
okay again I'm just trying to make it
simpler so in the system what we do we
assemble multiple components okay uh
I'll just stop sharing my uh the webcam
because I'm facing some bandwidth issues
sorry about that okay so the system
actually when we speak about that it is
an assembly of different components for
specified requirements and when we said
design we speak mainly about how
efficiently this different components
whatever we have as assembled okay so
that's that's the main thing that we
need to understand like for example if
you see here we have Instagram Facebook
Uber WhatsApp YouTube all these things
starts from the Slate or the black white
board from there thing starts right
so now how do we approach this if you if
it is coming in an interview okay
because this is how it may be an
interview or may be in your work
practices if this question is given to
you how do you approach that okay the
answer is simple you need to First sit
down and understand what and all the
requirements you want to get first there
are two different categories okay one is
functional other understand functional
yes we see them what are those two
different things are we considering here
okay I'll talk about that in a while for
an example we'll be taking Instagram
again but before then let's go through
those steps what and all we need to
consider okay and we'll be talking about
the estimations when we say estimations
it's it's very simple saying that what
capacity will have for example uh like
let's say a crucial point to keep in
mind in this kind of first situation is
the number of reading requests will be
100 times higher than the number of
uploads okay other are the writing
requests okay I'll come to that again
this is mainly about the capacity for
one day I will show you in literally in
a way where you can understand you know
you know piece of paper
and then we'll understand eye level
design there we'll talk about
architecture
um then user on how do we onboard the
user that means signing up how do we
store the users what cluster will be
using what cache mechanism will be using
and how do we store all those things
where Kafka comes into a picture and all
those things what is Kafka so again
those pointers and then we'll talk about
data model in this one we'll be talking
about what components are there and what
all the data models will be having it
can be database or it can be anything
okay it can be fitted database let's say
a photo is a table users a table user
flow is the table there are multiple
components again in here we'll see that
okay and eye level design
here I'll be talking about again
detailed architecture of what is load
balancer comes in where my cache comes
in where my Kafka comes in all these
things okay that's what we talk about in
the in this particular
enable design in return design whatever
I told in the eye level I have to
elaboratively explain to make sure the
interviewer are in your application your
application
uh this all these components whatever we
have will be need to explain for
unjustify why I am using this if you are
having a work if it is question is if a
requirement is given to you may be
designing a complex system like
Instagram or may it be a simple
functionality you need to start in a
specific Manner and this is what the
manner I'm giving you so this is the
kind of a handbook for you guys to
whenever a task is given to develop you
need to follow these specific steps okay
after that uh then let's understand how
do how does an application work for a
newbies this would be a very useful uh
like diagram because in this diagram it
says end to end what exactly happens in
a brief okay first of all what do we do
as a user I collect data from the user
what collect data again it can be
username password if they are signing up
then I can capture the data for username
password on the first name last name
mattress phone number etc etc etc okay
and again how this is been done okay
whenever you say google.com Okay and
sign up it goes to the back end get some
HTML CSS JavaScript contents and display
it to you you will enter some
information and goes to the back end and
test the next further processing okay
when I say that how that happens it'll
go top to the backend server whatever we
have we will make sure that it will
communicates database also it
communicates to the file system whatever
it needs to display in the UI and
finally you get the response this is how
this all communication works right so
that's about this entire end-to-end
application working looks like right
now what and all things one has to
consider when we actually have a
giveness system design question to you
guys
now what are the different architectural
pieces
that can be used to solve given a
question that is very important and now
how do we what are the different pieces
we have at this point and how do I
integrate them that becomes a very
crucial part in it okay and also we need
to make sure that how can we best
utilize those pieces with trade-off when
I say trade-off are we leaving 10
complexity for a space complexity or are
we compromising with one another or we
have to think whenever a question is
given to you you always need to choose
one or the other that is what caps
theorem is all about I'll talk to talk
about that in a while what is Cap
theorem and how useful it is for us
right
so that is one thing and then system
design and components what all the
components when we are actually going to
build a system they need to consider
these are the components we have load
balancing or we have caching we have SQL
nosql we have gateways we have cap
theorem and many more this is this is a
very big list of things which we'll be
considering okay if I have to mention in
apart from this we have data
partitioning we have indexes we have
proxies
redundancy replication
long polling web socket server sent
events
what else and whatnot that the list
keeps growing bigger because those many
things one has to know to actually build
the system if you are feeling
overwhelming don't bother about that
that's why I've given you the concepts
which are catchy enough and needed for
you guys to
at this point just get started with you
guys folks who are seeing for the first
time these are your starting points for
you guys to
start your journey towards the system
design
okay out of which I want to speak about
first Topic in this entire
many more are the big concept that is
what is load balancing okay load
balancing or a load balancer is one of
the critical component of any
distributed systems okay what does it do
it helps to spread the traffic across
the cluster of servers okay if you guys
know server well and good server means
the the system the kind of
place where you get the request okay and
from there we decide what response I
need to send now this server let's take
an example of
Instagram because we're talking about
that now at every given point of time I
get
thousands of requests to make sure to
see generally in the Instagram the
requests are mainly for news feeds when
I say news feeds you open Instagram just
to scroll up and just check what all the
information we have made to check reels
to check your friends post or the
general news feed whatever as I followed
okay those information are the ones you
guys are looking here to
balance out like for example I get if I
get 10 requests I'm fine with one server
let's suppose my system is not able to
handle Beyond 10 request then what I'm
supposed to do what I'm supposed to do
is I need to add multiple servers and I
need to keep one middle guy called as
load balancer what is the responsibility
of load balancer a balancer what you
need to do if you get a request till 100
you send it to me the first server if
you get request Beyond Android you root
it to second one if you get Beyond 100
200 you send it a third one again like
that if I have 10 servers those requests
are properly segregated right how there
is a strategy for that to do that and
what is that the one I'm showing you
there are round robin fashion of
allocating servers in the system
dynamically okay
guys is my voice not clear to everyone
or is my voice not audible to any like
is it low
and I'm hearing it fine
yeah but there are some folks who are
complaining about the voice
thank you folks I'll carry on
so in this one there are three to four
like many
many actually strategies we have we have
round robin we have IP hash don't bother
about this techniques understand that
these techniques are used to make sure
if you get hundreds of requests how do I
make sure my request is let's say this
IPS user one this IPC is a two this
episode three or if these IPS user one
is 201
okay I keep on routing such IPS in
different different places why because I
need to make sure that those requests
are not bumped upon in one single server
and make it heavy and that's what
happens latency increases so by
balancing those information my system
will not break because of huge request
coming in it's always distributed across
multiple servers okay that is why load
balancing is a very very very crucial
topic if I want to give you the best
example for this is your hot star okay
how hot star the day India Pakistan
match is there for example coming Sunday
you go and check the previous day you'll
have maybe 10 lakhs people are watching
a match the next day you will
automatically see one crore people are
watching the match how do they scale up
that much you need to think okay
whenever you see such a problems first
of all you have to think what is the
purpose how people are handling such a
request from 10 lakhs to one crore
that's where this load balancers plays a
very vital role on handling all the
requests coming in smoothly sending them
back this ensures no single server bears
not too much demand rather than
splitting it across or spreading it
across evenly across all the servers
that's why load balancing improves
application responsiveness okay it also
increases availability of the
application and websites for users why I
say this point because when I say
availability the system whenever I open
or start it is available for me to watch
cricket match okay or if I open
Instagram it is available for me to
browse my photos or have my news feeds
that's what I mean by availability over
here okay this whatever I am telling
about uh this load balancing right this
can not just only happen in the front
end to other web servers this can happen
at every stage okay maybe application
server may be database server may be
whatever other components we have okay
load balancer is also one of the server
yes it is responsibilities to redirect
the request to specific servers that's
it to the back end if you want to say
okay it's like a traffic signal it
redirects whichever guys you come you go
okay like that it is or maybe if you go
to a tall okay if you tall Booth if you
guys all remember
or not all of us will go to single talls
right there are multiple tall boots for
us and we ourselves redirected to
separate talls we are actually load
balancing ourselves for us in software
someone does that responsibility now the
road suddenly widens up the moment we
would scroll both right how does that
out because there are already predefined
booths to cross across that is what you
call it as servers server one server two
server three server Etc in our case that
split will not automatically happen and
that's the reason load balancer will
play that role to split those requests
to multiple people okay that is what the
main use of load balancer and this is
exactly is used in Instagram uh like
designing also okay
my point here is to talk about all these
Basics it is very important when I speak
about load balancing in Instagram design
okay
so these are the some techniques now
that is done with the word balancing now
the next topic is
okay what is caching okay
means now if you see this example this
is a wonderful example now to make you
all understand what actually happens if
the caching is not in place let's
understand that okay for the first thing
we want the caching is there visitor one
comes here I have a visitor okay I just
say Okay I need the page and the page
name is
www.instagram.com okay and now system
what will take place it will now so okay
go and check a cache do you have
instagram.com in your page or in your
cachet do you cache it no I will as of
no I don't have I'll build it so what
happens there is some back-end
processing happens and finally it
reaches database in database we have
those information about the Instagram or
whatever information I'm looking at it
takes it back and passes it back through
the cache saving the data not everything
is saved in the cache only necessary
information is saved in the cache and
this request is sent back now
next time
this is with caching
okay this is what happens second user
comes in now right what he does is hey I
need the page and the page is
www.instagram.com and now it goes to the
back end and now instead of me going
through all the layers and reaching
database I have already cached this page
in my system just like your RAM whatever
we have okay this information is stored
in the cache and now that has been
returned back to the user so this is the
main purpose of cache Okay so
this without this and with this there's
a lot of difference the main problem is
this increases latency latency means the
fetch time will automatically grow high
and that is being avoided for us with
the help of caffeine okay that's why
cash cache plays a very important role
in the system design World okay so now
if you see where and all we can have
cache is one of the very crucial things
people generally miss out okay the Cache
can be present in browser for a browser
cache or it also can be part of page
page cache we can also keep a CDN cache
we can have a database cache and we can
have all possible layers each and every
component
places we can add our cache in place
okay that is the main reason cache is
used so these are some of the places so
if you see this is the one cache this is
second this is third this is fourth this
is fifth truly there are five different
places where we can have actually okay
let me move on
okay
so these are eviction policies okay what
is electric policies eviction means
now let's say my cache size is I'll just
about one eviction policy here I'll give
an example for you guys how this
eviction policy works
these are some of the official policies
I'll give you one example in detail okay
and that is
let's say I have first in first out
I have these are the some of the
chatologies okay I have first in first
out last in first out least recently
used most recently used last frequently
used are randomly replacement discuss
about the strategies okay in each and
everything we will have one different
strategy now I want to pick one of these
and I'll explain you in detail about
that particular cache okay in that which
I am going to pick here is
I'm gonna pick lru so that you always
understand how do we use it right I'll
just show you
okay now foreign there are two things
which are used for us and what is that
one first component is
linked list and the second component is
hash mark I'll just show you other
series and I made this I made it as an
empty page to write and show you guys
okay now
let's say the request comes in
let me open a notepad plus plus sorry
it's from here
now
let's say that the request comes in
whenever I request comes in let's say I
have a request one
okay and then it passes information as a
now I am looking for a as a page what
happens let's suppose I have this
information in my cache and I have
doubly linked list and I have a hash map
this is my hash map
this is also kind of an algorithm which
is used for for a lru and this is
linked list
I am telling you again this is a doubly
linked list now a comes in what happens
it moves here to the cache
okay and also it adds this information
in the dash map now second comes in is B
let's suppose my cash size is 4 only now
I'll add this to the B
sorry this will be reversed
so
you will have V here
whenever the whatever the release
recently used that means lru that comes
in the first whenever B comes in EA will
be pushed back to the second place and B
will be added over here
okay because whatever least recently
used will be considered first
okay so this is the one now this came at
last and this was considered now a now
next time let's say I get a only then
this gets swapped like this a will
become first B will be afterwards after
this let's say I get C and make in the
hash map let's say this is also four and
this also is 4. okay next I get C then C
will be added next I get C will be added
not here but in the beginning
look like in the hash map it doesn't
matter it will add all the values now
cash is full now in future let's say I
get D and also I get e or if I get e
because size is already filled right now
what happens in this big list what is
least recently used how do we decide
that we decide that only by the element
present in the last location in this
case b is the element which is present
in the last location so I describe this
now my new cache will have here at the
beginning because B wasn't the last
location my cache is currently filled
with data I'll move this data outside of
the cache and this is called as eviction
policy remember very important word
fiction policy this is whatever we are
discussing okay and now let's say I get
a again if I get a no here also it will
remove B and adds e over here in the
hash map in both of them we will
actually maintain this items here linked
list this is to maintain
the sequence
of least recently used
and this is mainly for number of
elements
okay not to maintain the duplicacy okay
and now next let's say let's say now now
I get again one more time here
then what happens this sequence will
automatically get modified to a e
D and C this goes on this particular
idea goes on this is how least recently
used element cache works or sorry
strategy works
least recently
used
caching this is okay why I'm explaining
this because
one has to know a strategy how cache
Works in that context this becomes
extremely important for us to understand
or any cache I don't mind explaining
about any one of this the same way
discarding happens based on the strategy
here first thing first out you all know
whatever comes first in goes out first
in already removes again last in first
note we have I showed you just know
about lru next most recently used will
be removed first the different caching
strategies or eviction policies there
okay that's how these things works now
again we have different kinds of SQL and
nosql okay why this is I'm talking about
here
for us it is extremely important to
understand
which database we are using for let's
say we have data that is manageable up
to thousands or maybe lacks it's okay
for us to use in normal table based
databases but the moment if the data
increases right the moment data
increases it's always recommended for us
to always go and go for no SQL databases
nowadays this is very much popular than
this because this is old school why I'm
saying that because this follows table
based okay table based approach it
follows so whereas this is having
different strategies and in this also
everything gathers a different use cases
now if I see graph databases this
scatters maybe mainly for now if I
discussing about maybe a and ml this is
used a lot again if you want to do a lot
of uh data manipulation maybe if you're
using um data grid tool
to show all those data okay all data
analytics tools then graph database is
very commonly used when you have big we
use data and then if you want to access
the data and if there is you don't have
don't want to have the Restriction of
how those data is saved maybe just like
your uh Json okay I have a b and in
again in the B further again we have
B split across multiple things all these
things this again talking about one
example of document
this is also one of the very famous
example of document databases again and
which one we have in this very famous is
in Market currently going on is the
mongodb
okay these are the things currently we
have and very important for us to
understand all these things
okay now let's move on to the next uh
thing and that is Instagram now all
these Basics why I told you because it
is extremely important for us to
understand before I talk about this
actual Instagram design that's the
reason before jumping on to the system
design of Instagram I want to make sure
to explain the components to at least
get with my pace of understanding so
that you can get those knowledge in a
seamless way okay now my question is
design Instagram okay it's not that
simple whenever a question is given to
you you need to make sure you gather
those
functional and non-functional
requirements okay what is functional
requirement like I already mentioned it
talks about main functionality of a
given system
okay in this one what and all the
functional requirements we guys can
actually have photo should be able to
uploaded by and view by users very very
primary use case of an Instagram is
photos right and that is what we are
considering here as mainly photos should
be uploaded downloaded and also viewed
by all the users users can search for
photos based on their videos or base
sorry based on their titles even that's
important okay
and then we have
followers okay you follow XYZ person and
you follow and they follow you both of
you should be able to feed each other to
one another so that whatever happens in
your system in your uh Fates should be
sent to him whatever happens to igneous
system should be fed to you vice versa
should always happen and that's why this
third requirement is also important we
are gathering the requirements now to
make sure that how do I build those
things okay this is the first
requirement I gathered
and I need to work on this and I'll
think about it this second requirement
this is third requirement and this can
be let's say I have a top celebrity okay
maybe we are calling okay and we should
follow is let's say you guys followed it
and you need to get feed from him every
single time
okay in order to get feed from him every
single day whatever he does okay and how
do we build those those information we
are mainly going to focus here right and
then
function requirements is done maybe you
guys are hearing this for the first time
now the second and very crucial part
what is that non-functional requirements
people get often confused with these
things especially the people who are
understanding or getting this topic for
the first time right
what are non-functional requirements now
you have built the Instagram very good
I'm happy about it now is it available
to users all the time or not or what
about the latency okay latency means the
moment I open I should see the system
feed automatically running in so that's
what latency how much this latency we
can allow so and that's what we are
giving us 200 milliseconds that means
very very less latency I have and
whatever consistency what is consistency
I'll give an example okay
let's say that you you upload a photo
okay you upload a photo and
you if you upload a photo it immediately
might not come in the others field
okay it might not come in the other
screen immediately
because
goes to system loads in somewhere we'll
discuss about that in detail and finally
it has to identify your all the
followers then go and feed when they
open it should be visible or to weave in
your profile on it will take some time
but and that is okay for us
for me if I open Instagram what is the
very minimum expectation is I need to
see news feed seamlessly that is my
minimum expectation
and if I see the uploading of the photo
a little late I don't mind
okay and that is what this Instagram's
main I mean I am considering all these
points as a very important thing and
reliability what is reliability
now if I open the system how much
reliable I can on this okay
it should be highly reliable means
wherever I offer Instagram however I put
Instagram if it can be mobile and it can
be system it can be tablet whatever the
moment I open I should be able to get
the data without fail
that is what reliability we can drill
Instagram for any of our businesses or
and as business ads things and all and
if I go and say these are the people my
post should come then those things will
definitely will be appearing in their
users feeds and that's what we call it
as reliability and that is a very very
important consideration for us
okay then what else let's move on now we
have actually got all the system
non-functional and functional
requirements okay now these are my
design considerations now I am building
the design now what and all I need to
keep in my mind okay my system is read
heavy okay when I say read heavy how
often you tell out you guys only think
about yourself
how often you upload or how often in if
you open Instagram let's say 10 times a
day okay in that 10 times how often you
upload a video or you view the news feed
99 you just go for the feeds okay but
other
one person to go for
go first 99 you go for
just checking the news feed what what's
happening in some others life and that's
what called as read heavy operation we
mainly focus on news feed okay that
means system can retrieve photo quickly
and that is very very important
okay and when we do that the latency
should be bare minimum that means while
viewing this photo it should not take a
lot of time for loading those photo and
that is one of the major and major
consideration when we are building an
application like Instagram
okay so and now let's say I upload the
user I upload a photo I don't mind
the photo comes after a minute
but desperately I mind
okay
okay definitely I mind if my photo is
not at all uploaded or if it is lost I
definitely mind this
is extremely important this is what
called as reliability whatever I do the
operation that has to be present in the
system no matter what that's what we
call it as reliability okay now these
are some of the design concentrations I
am making making before I start
designing my actual Instagram now
capacity estimation The crucial point to
keep in mind is that the number of
requests will be
1000 times higher than whatever the
number of writing requests same thing we
discussed here
did Heavy
means
people always expect to load the data
then upload the photo to the system okay
let's assume that we have 500 registered
users in our platform okay okay in that
we have let's say only one million
active users every day
okay if 5 million images are posted
every day the number of photos uploaded
in one second is is the estimation I'm
making here now let's say this one I'll
make a new estimation if 5 million
images are posted every single day that
means the number of photos appeared in
every second is one second
is equals to 5 million
into
24 hours
60 minutes
60 Seconds
okay if you sorry if this is a division
I'm sorry if you divide by this what
happens approximately this is
approximation
you would be getting 57 photos
will be uploaded every single second
this is the estimation I am making based
on my current assumption
okay
I repeat I am making based on the
current assumption okay now let's say
each and every photo okay each and every
photo is of size 150 KB here I'm telling
200 I can have 150 also now now I I want
to show differently than this so I'm
taking these different numbers here for
you guys now let's say 5 million photo
whatever I have now if I multiply this
with let's say 150 KB I have for each
for every photo
then it will approximately come up or
come up to
716 GB
okay this is how storage for us this is
one day storage for us
you need to do same way in your
interviews whenever question is given to
you you need to take some approximations
and keep on building on top of it to
achieve to the end goal always make
capacity estimations that will also help
you in understanding what data I will be
needing okay so that's that's the one
more estimation I wanted to make and now
third thing is now let's say if we
assume our service continue for next 10
years just like this
716 GB if I talk about
e65 days
into 10 years it would approximately
come up to
2500 and
53 terabyte of data I will be needing
okay so totally it is approximately
2.6 petabytes of data and I need
okay this number is extremely useful for
us because one has to understand how
much data we we need to keep or my
database what is the capacity you should
have in growing ages this is I'm roughly
calculating as of today now if tomorrow
or or in coming days user base increases
this number can grow exponentially okay
this number can grow exponentially now
if I talk about different estimations
whatever present in here let us see how
that number looks like I showed you for
5 million now here I have took 2 million
photos uploaded every single day then it
will leave up to 23 new photos every
single day if one photo having 200 KB it
would result in four and 400 GB of data
the storage we want for one day of
photos now if I talk about 10 years it
would it would cost me I would I would
be wanting 1.4
petabytes of data will be requiring
okay this is how you need to make the
capacity estimation once you make the
capacity estimation you now are a
picture in your mind okay this is how I
this much data I want now I am building
the system for this heavy information
which comes through my system and passes
on okay now the next topic is how do I
talk about high level design if you
notice in the initial slide I have shown
you guys how to go step by step first
step I told you to do design or capacity
estimations that is exactly the same
thing I just now did now I am moving on
to high level design okay because we
have shortage of time I'll be for a
little bit making it faster Okay so
here we have user onboarding this
scanner two different flows one is
login flow other one is can be
sign up flow two different flows I'll be
having onboarding can be of both the
things okay it goes to user service this
will be a again here I have wrote load
balancers I can have one two three four
Etc
I can have multiple servers here that is
why lb comes in it generally routes like
this
okay and then it goes let's say uh I do
all the necessary modification or
necessary uh changes needs to my server
and then I will be saving this data to
the myself uh database again here also
the
LV can come in load of answer can come
in otherwise again the cluster means
that only it is one like this I can have
multiple
okay now this data is put in the back
end and it is saved and here we go we
have a cache redis is a cache okay it is
generally maintained in the service
layer side okay once you save a database
we always will come and write the
come and write this information in the
cache also once the data is written in
the cache that will be sent back to the
user user who's ever seeing and that is
onboarding okay now let's say I added to
the friend if I add the friend and that
is coming to the back end with the load
virus setup will look at this graph
service I have why because that add
friend can be gay thread of b b student
of c c is friend of D again D can be
filtered off a A can be found off C this
combination moving across the different
friends can easily be achieved with the
help of graph databases here okay I am
just showing you MySQL because of the
just for the sake of Designing the eye
level but if you really talk about them
we need to have one information in the
back end and that can be also of graph
which will help us easily navigate
across different things and we have
Kafka Kafka is mainly to redirect it's
just to make make things faster and
multi-processed okay it will just
channelize multiple things in multiple
way without independencies let's not
discuss today because we don't have that
much of time to discuss all these things
so this is how high level design of a
system would look like now
moving on
if I have time I would have explained
even more in detail
let's understand overall components
whatever we have in the system okay now
I can have like this I can have other
components also but for the sake of
short time limit I am showing you this
information I have new user field
service I have follow our service every
service will talk to the back end
remember that
they will make sure that the data is if
you notice here neo4j which is a graph
database
okay why I told you that database
because Friend Is A Friend Is A Friend
Is A Friend friend of friend of friend
of friend can be a friend of first
friend that combination can be easily
achieved with the help of graph that is
the main reason we have this graduate in
the back end and we have user field
service we have follower Service Media
hosting service this is mainly for your
photos and videos
okay and we have post whatever post you
make you you make post like this right
you have a photo and you write something
and it will be image you have
okay this is what this information will
be saved in post service and we have
comments whatever comments is made to
the new system and that comes here we
have live service for every small
component we have its their own services
okay and Cassandra is a column based
database and that is used for this
student database now let's talk about
database design this I don't want to
complicate I'm keeping it simple I have
three information one is your photo
table first one second one user table
whatever user follow or stable here I
gather about user ID photo path
longitude latitude on all this
information to locate the user data okay
or the location wait user current will
tend to login under creation date you
all tell right access by location
whenever you grant your location you
know what happens in the behind the
scenes these information are passed on
to the back end all of you should
understand whenever you open your mobile
phone when you say share my location
these are the information generally will
be saved to the system and based on that
longitude latitude of information you
will be tracked okay so and then we have
user ID here we have name email address
birth date of birth create last login
this information are specific to the
user and here followers they say a
follows Bing okay we follow C
and then C follows d
okay
if I can follow this this can happen how
all this communication is saved and
these are saved in the user flow or user
followers diagram okay
so I would like to stop at this
particular Point uh but this was
actually I added this user in news feed
information where data comes in and once
you upload it goes to the back end and
data backing database this photo will be
uploaded in the database again we'll be
using this S3 bucket for saving those
data in the cloud and this again we will
be reading writing back the photo for a
specific
database this is a upload image work
this so view image works both are follow
similar pattern
okay and if I talk about load balancing
in Instagram
every data comes through goes through
application servers will obviously be
cached okay caching is done for every
information coming in because
now save user coming and asking me feed
data every single time I can't keep
providing them again from a device every
single time if it is Data is frequently
used let's say Virat Kohli is called
Sanctuary that image will be accessed by
millions of billions of users I can't go
to databaseable single Diamond pastel
image right now I'll do I'll keep this
let's say we are call this image in the
caching every time people ask for this
information I'll retribution it back the
user I will do this there are again
different strategies of how to maintain
the celebrities information non
celebrity information there are multiple
strategies but let's not focus on that
my point is just to talk about all these
different
like lb techniques okay and uh
that's all for today I have from my side
I think it's nine
yeah
um
yeah
preventer I think you have a hard stop
is that correct yeah actually
okay
um so what I'm going to do is I'll take
it from here and I want to apologize we
have a few questions
um but I'll pass questions maybe I can
take two three minutes more
okay
um
it's the Lord balancing done through a
separate server
actually yes even that's also one place
where it is done in separate server yeah
that's correct okay and sign up asks how
uh algorithm lru works with hashmap
okay basically how hashmap works is Ash
map is mainly used to maintain those
information let's say I have five
information a b c d e
asthma is used for saving it or you can
use set also to not to have duplicate
data okay that is the reason we use as
Mac and for least recently used we use
linked list the combination of these two
is used to achieve the lro technique
excellent thank you um if you will email
me afterward when you get a chance for
adventure if you email me the PowerPoint
I will make a PDF of the slides and
share that with the audience sure I'll
send it to you after this session Stuart
I appreciate that and um just want to
let everybody know I will be sending out
a follow-up email with that link and
link to the recording
so that you'll be able to review
what Greg vendor spoke about today and
Rick vendor thank you I'm going to let
you go and I'll continue on to the rest
of the presentation thank you so much
Stuart thank you so much guys I hope you
all understood something useful for from
Twitter session and uh there will be a
search vertical showing what this mainly
in we do in this uh simply learn
sessions and I hope and I hope you get
those points as well from him and I wish
you all the very best and have a good
night guys or good morning from wherever
you are yeah okay thank you bye-bye and
uh
what I want to talk about just before we
finish
is one of the programs that we have
you've seen a lesson we have different
courses available through our
simplylearn.com website one of which for
people in India specifically
is the full stack Java developer program
with a 100 job guarantee
QR code will take you to that program
page but basically what it is is a six
month program with a comprehensive
curriculum where you have live
interactive classes similar to one you
just were in but with more tools
available so
follow along do the exercises with the
instructor and
um
it allows you to access the other course
materials 24 7 so between your weekly
classes you can catch up all the other
material for Preparation and projects
and this particular program includes a
guaranteed job offer on completion
meaning once you finish the six month
program it we will give you a job search
support for six months and at the end of
that additional six months if you
haven't gotten a job with one of our
company Partners we will refund your
program fees so
the curriculum starts off with the
object-oriented programming Java
understanding data structures algorithms
so
then you become a back-end expert with
courses on the back end processes you
look at Frameworks and devops and then
the front end and ultimately you finish
with a Capstone project where you tile
those skills together into a finished
project that you can then use as part of
your portfolio and demonstrate your
experience to
lawyers you also have the elective of
taking a testing and devops
of course
and
again what you get out of this is you
get your certification you get
26 or so projects along the way you can
choose your Capstone project from four
different industry domains and the job
guarantee program
it's only available at this point in
India I apologize to anyone in other
countries watching today
um
based on this really brief thumbnail I
just wanted to ask uh how many people in
the audience might be interested in this
program so
let me ask this quick poll question for
you
keep this open for about 30 seconds
and I'm going to
in the meantime get the information oops
sorry
about sharing that
okay and we'll close the poll
okay
so about three quarters of the folks in
the audience are interested in this
program you look in the chat box you'll
see a link the same link as that QR code
and you'll also see the email address
ask us at simplylearn.net where you can
contact one of our learning Consultants
to ask uh additional questions
let's see if this is something you'd
like to enroll in
so with that
just want to say thank you to everybody
here for attending we really appreciate
that we do have an upcoming webinar for
people who are looking
for new jobs in
software development so again I will put
this information in the chat but you can
scan that QR code it'll take you to the
registration page for this webinar
um where just about a subnautio of
GitHub will talk about what it's like to
be on both sides of the interviewing
process
um she recently went through the process
to get her new position at GitHub and
she also interviews
software developers to join her team so
she can give you advice on
What to Expect When You're interviewing
look at it from both perspectives
with that I want to invite everyone
to join us on our
social media channels at simplylearn on
Facebook and Twitter simply learn on
LinkedIn and
with that I'd like to conclude the
webinar so we hope that we can welcome
you into our simply learned learning
community and we hope to see you at
future webinars thank you so much